[Musique]
smart nos amis
bonsoir aujourd'hui c'est pain que ce
patch pas que nous sommes tous contents
lol lol lol lol alors nous avons
rencontré des clash dans le ciel nous
ont donné ce bel oeuf de pâques pour
nicolas et pimprenelle lavit et leurs
partenaires sont l'échelle se portent
pas que nous sommes tous contents holl
holl holl holl holl holl holl était gay
c'est ce qu'est ce que tu nous as pas
c'était ne nous avons vu les oeufs et
vous en donner ces taxes oui elles nous
l'ont confié pour qu'on vous le taux
n'est tenu la neige et les débats posez
le sur la table et ouvre le je crois
bien qu'il contient quelques souffrir
voit la patte ans ou non
petit plus c'est qu'il est ministre
j'ai bien sûr ils sortent de son oeuf
oui dois voir ça moi je vais le chercher
des graines des ti
[Musique]
tiens poucet ou la soif mulhouse je vais
chercher de l'eau petit pouce aux tiens
j'allais poussa doivent nous maintenons
ce qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
oui il va s'ennuyer six ans seulement il
saurait mieux à la campagne la conjointe
de m
nous nous amener à la campagne non non
tu veux trouvera une maman poule
excellente idée les enfants il sera
beaucoup plus heureux avec une maman
poule allons petit poussin on retourne
dans ton nom et s'est vite au dos tu
vois nous aussi on va se coucher on
irait de voir à la campagne et soit bien
sage alors poussons tu le pr août
annoncée ni de nuit les petits
un dogme
la jette à la lumière bonnet pas preneur
d'aubiet nicolas vonn eu des enfants
allez vous coucher vite vite nous aussi
patron partons vite vite
nous devons ramener le petit poussin
chez sa maman est bien en route nounours
d'ennui fêtes de beaurains
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]